Surprisingly, in this case, the answer is the global object.
When you don't have a dot to help you pass a specific binding for
the keyword this, JavaScript binds this by default to the global object.
This can be seen as similar to the fact that JavaScript binds undefined to
positional parameters when we call the function without enough inputs.
So if we had passed no inputs in between these parentheses,
we would expect one and two to be undefined.
A similar line of reasoning leads us to the conclusion that the default object
of global would be bound to this whenever we don't have a dot.
The dot is the mechanism by which we pass in a binding for the keyword this.
So without a dot,
you could expect that some default value to get bound to the parameter this.